[Music]
there's been a lot about you in the
tabloids recently uh the the tabloids
have been speculating and they've been
saying uh courtney's having an affair
with her co-star
josh hamilton from cougar town and
i'm sorry i'm sorry josh hopkins uh uh i
dated him briefly but i forgot his name
uh
but they're saying that you two are
dating and uh and then they have these
pictures of you that really do look
like you're very much in love i mean
there you are and i'm just curious this
is your chance to
to clear the record what's happening
here well i don't want to
burst anyone's bubble but
josh's dad larry
happens to be a big fan of the two of us
being together if you saw his phone
there's a picture of josh and i on his
screensaver so this man is so sweet and
the fact that he really likes the
thought of us being together when i see
paparazzi i'll be like josh let's do
this for larry and i'll look at him
longingly like i just love him so much i
do love him and you know i don't want to
burst larry's bubble
but that's kind of different so you're
just doing that to to as a favor to his
father to make him
yes i hope he's not watching because i
really i still i love that he likes me
so much
yeah well i'm sure he still likes you
whenever andy and i are spotted by
paparazzi we do the same thing you do
i always carry a tonight pillow
[Applause]
[Laughter]
those photos just break my wife's heart
yeah